(soft music)
- You eat my chicken all the time.
- I am not.
Yours looks better.
(laughs)
So, today's a special day.
Got anything planned?
- What day is it?
- What month is it?
- Let me think.
Think, Eli.
- I think it's February.
It's February.
- Oh my god, it's Valentine's Day.
- Oh, are you serious?
- Okay, okay, what do we have planned?
(sighs)
- We got Chili's!
(men cheer "Chili's" in unison)
- Dinner and a movie.
- That's it?
- We got to up the romance.
Up, up, up.
- Okay, up the romance.
Up the romance.
What did we do last Valentine's Day?
- That was around the, the,
the Superbowl.
- Yeah, oh man.
- What a game.
- We have to focus!
- Oh, um...I got it.
- Oh like, sip a little
bubbly, walk along the beach.
You know.
- What do you want from us, woman?
- I think it's time to go full romance.
(sirens blare)
- No, we haven't even recovered
from our anniversary.
- We can't.
He'll be torn apart.
- No, his body can take it.
- He set the bar low for a reason.
- He just got that raise.
- That's it.
We're going full romance!
You know, I didn't want
to ruin the surprise,
but, you know, rose petals.
Put on that baby making mix.
And feel up on that--
- Wait.
Are you talking about your mom?
You know she's coming
to town today, right?
(men sigh in relief)
- Yeah.
- You thought it was Valentine's Day.
- I knew my mom was coming to town.
What are you talking about?
- That was a close one.
- Man.
- Wait.
What are we gonna do when Mom gets here?
- Chili's!
- (cheer in unison) Chili's!